suppose one part of the universe wants
to tell another part of the universe
what to do point a wants to tell point B
what temperature to be that information
can't travel faster than the speed of
light so on very large scales there's no
way that one part of the universe knew
to be 3 Kelvin and another part of the
universe knew to be 3 Kelvin so how do
you explain that and what Alan goth and
Company did was basically to explain it
and that is to say that at some earlier
time the universe was so small that
regions that are now now too far apart
to talk to each other were perfectly
happy in confabulation early on and then
the universe expanded exponentially
which we can call inflation it had to be
in causal contact at some early time and
that's behind inflation